as you know we are currently
crowdfunding Snow White and the Widow
Queen so if you haven't backed that
project yet please go ahead and do that
this video is a patron only video that I
put out a few years ago on Jack and the
Beanstalk kind of interpreting the
relationship between the seed hierarchy
you know what exactly is going on it's a
story that I've been very curious about
since I was a child and it will be one
of the stories that we'll we will be
putting out in this fairy tale series
that we're starting with Snow White and
the Widow Queen so please enjoy
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
the story of Jack and the Beanstalk is a
story that we've all heard as North
Americans we know that story quite well
so I thought it would be interesting to
explore that story to look at its
structure to look at the symbolism
inherent in it and uh also it will help
us to see a certain perspective on
symbolism a certain perspective on
hierarchy which is the manner in which
hierarchy can prevent let's say things
from higher above from reaching us
something like that so we'll uh it's a
it's an aspect of hierarchy that I
haven't looked at so much and so I hope
that it'll be a good occasion to talk
about that the story of Jack and the
Beanstalk can be
um brought into very simple elements you
know there are different versions of it
of course but the most known version the
one remember I'm gonna tell it very
briefly a young boy lives with his
mother he's an orphan he uh his mother
is quite poor and uh you know they're
starving they have nothing to eat and
finally
his mother you know all they have is
this one cow and they're at the end of
their rope and finally his mother tells
him you know go and sell our cow so that
we can eat you know for one last time
and then we can die something like that
and so Jack goes out and um
he goes out with the cow in order to
sell it at the market and hoping to be
able to buy some food but on the way
Jack makes a strange old man and a
strange old man is suggests that maybe
Jack should trade his cow for these
magic beans
um and he tells them that these magic
beans are very special very precious and
Jack ends up accepting that deal he
takes the magic beans brings them back
to his mother and of course his mother
is extremely annoyed what are these
magic beans you've been duped you've
been had and she tosses the magic beans
outside the window the next morning Jack
wakes up and the beans have transformed
in this gigantic Beanstalk which goes
all the way up into the sky into the
clouds and so Jack starts to ascend this
um this stock his mother of course
doesn't want him to but Jack will go
anyways he ascends the stock and
arriving up in the clouds he finds there
is a giant castle or a house or or or
some kind of Lair and in in front of the
lair is a giant woman and the woman
tells him you know be careful be careful
because my husband is coming my husband
the ogre is coming
and so his this giant comes in you know
fee fifo thumb I smell the blood of an
Englishman and uh the uh the woman hides
Jack in their house so the the giant
sits down and he uh he eats and after
he's eaten he takes out his bag of money
and then he and and he starts to count
it Jack and see this from his hiding
place and finally the giant falls asleep
of course Jack goes in takes the bag of
gold brings it down the Beanstalk to his
mother and this happens three times
where he goes up the second time he goes
up the same thing happens but instead of
a bag of coins usually it is a chicken
that lays golden eggs and then the third
time that he goes up usually what it is
it's a magical harp which plays music on
its own and when Jack takes it the
sometimes the harp will call out to its
master and uh the giant wakes up chases
um
chases Jack down the Beanstalk his
mother cuts the Beanstalk and the giant
falls down you know and uh and dies and
then after that Jack and his mother live
happily ever after so that's the basic
elements of the structure but um let's
look at some of the elements one by one
and we'll see what it is it's trying to
talk about what type of structure is it
appealing to
so of course this idea of the the Jack
being a orphan living with his mother
having no father and being poor those
two things are related the notion of not
having enough uh enough to to be able to
survive enough money enough value you
could call it because the father is gone
the the uh he's left alone and poor with
his mother so he's not receiving what he
needs to receive from above you could
call it you have this relationship
between the rich and the poor the rich
are meant to give to the poor in order
to help them to to survive and the poor
you know are meant to provide work
provide you know uh support for those
that are above them you know and that's
how the the chain of value in terms of
monetary uh relationship goes you know
and so
um they are they're orphaned they're not
attached to any principle to any man to
any uh they're just left on their own
and so Jack goes to sell his cow and the
cow is of course you know the another
image of this this feminine image that
is related to his mother herself related
to the land related to you know the this
this is what they have they have the
land they they don't they don't have the
they don't have an identity they don't
have a family they're not connected to
something which can give them value and
uh and so Jack uh is the um the old man
wants to sell jack these beans now Jack
intuitively has understood the
transaction he he knows that that's what
he's looking for he's looking for seeds
he's looking for the center for a core
for a an attachment to meaning to an
attachment to an identity an attachment
to a family something which connects him
you know and will give him value and so
this seed is of course this image of the
core you know the the Pearl the uh the
littlest thing the center of the the
wheel so that's what he gets for the cow
so in in the Christian terms you could
say that he has sold the field to get
the Pearl that is in hidden in the field
you know Christ talks about about this
uh no if Christ actually no he says he
buys the field to get the uh the Pearl
but this is actually the opposite but it
ends up being the same thing it's like
you sacrifice the much for the few you
sacrifice you remove the garments of
skin you remove the animal in order to
get the seed you you get rid of the cow
and you get the center this this this uh
the center of meaning now
the the mother doesn't recognize the
seed she doesn't see it as something
that she can be attached to she doesn't
see the value in the seed that's often
the problem with the seed itself because
the seed the the meaning the name the
spiritual aspect of something usually
doesn't it's difficult for people to see
their value because it doesn't appear as
quantity it appears as as quality you
know you look at a seed of of a tree and
you think what is this this little thing
it's not worth anything it doesn't have
value you know you don't realize that if
you plant it into the ground then it
will become this gigantic tree you can't
see that people the the naive person
cannot see that in the tree but Jack has
perceived that if he has the seed then
he will have in the end he could have uh
I mean he doesn't necessarily
consciously do that but the idea is that
if he has the seed then later he can
have more because he can plant those
seeds and receive more now
the the mother tosses the seeds out and
then you have this stock which goes up
into the sky now the stock which goes
into the sky is this connection is the
connection to heaven it is the hierarchy
it is the mountain it is all those
things it is all these things which
connect Heaven and Earth so it is a it's
a connection between Heaven and Earth a
ladder like I said
um but it is a connection to heaven and
earth seen from Below
so you could imagine something like a
ray of light coming from above
um you can imagine that type of imagery
with something coming from above or you
know a a stream of water coming from
above or like I said array of light
um a glory from above but now it's from
the it's from the bottom up and so it is
this this vegetable stock which goes up
and reaches into the the sky and so uh
so Jack will Ascend the stock and what
is he going to get he's going to get
value he's trying to connect to meaning
to to to meaning in all the the ways
that that appears you know in terms of
identity in terms of having value on
Earth and so he goes up into the heaven
and he first off steals gold itself so
that's the first step it's like it's
like a hierarchy of things that he gets
the first is gold and and gold is of
course in our world it's value it's also
the highest metal it has to do with
light which comes down you can imagine
all these structures of the Golden Age
The Silver age the Bronze Age you can
imagine it as the the statue in the
dream of uh of the Prophet Daniel where
the head of the statue is gold and then
silver bronze and all the way down to
Clay so it's it is this hierarchy he
gets the gold
the second thing he gets is he gets the
production of gold he gets the uh uh you
know chicken which produces golden eggs
and in the golden egg what you get is
both the image of gold of value of this
Ray of Light which comes down from above
but also you can get it you can imagine
it also as the seed it is this egg it is
this this this uh the same as the it's
the Heavenly version of The Bean that uh
Jack got on earth now he's getting the
Heavenly version of that being the seed
that which comes from above and provides
uh anger provides meaning all of that
and then finally the third one is of
course the highest uh version which is
he receives this Golden Harp which plays
music on his own on its own and so here
it's related to the idea of a kind of
highest meaning in the sense of The
Music of the Spheres the patterns of
reality itself that is what he is
accessing when he gets the heart he's
accessing the the deepest meaning the
the pattern like I said the very pattern
by which the world is functioning so you
can see this hierarchy of things that
he's accessing as he is getting the
different things from the uh from the
Giant now
and then Jack what he does is he brings
the light down from heaven down to earth
and so he he it's of course the the
traditional hero's journey he goes to
get the Boon brings it back and that's
what he's doing he's going up into
heaven and he's getting some light from
Heaven he's getting some gold some seed
some patterns and he's bringing them
down to the Earth in order for them to
have their effect on the earth
um and so that's what he's doing now
the question comes is why is it that
Jack has to steal those from the Giants
why is it that Jack has to trick the
lady giant has to trick the Giants in
order to get that
light from above and here is where you
can see the hierarchy represented as an
obstacle and this is this is what is
being shown in the image now you can
understand it very simply cosmically or
phenomenologically you know you have you
have this experience of light where does
light come from light comes from above
that's where meaning comes from because
light get shows us the world and so
meaning comes from above and then
suddenly what happens this giant gray
cloud comes uh you know in front of the
sunlight and blocks the sunlight from
you
and so this is what this story is
referring to in terms of just phenomena
it's referring to the big dark clouds
the giant clouds that block the Sun from
us and prevent the sun its golden Rays
from coming down to us and so Jack has
to go up the Beanstalk has to go up what
he has he has to ascend this organic
this bottom-up uh ladder and get from
get from Heaven what it can get by by
stealing it from Heaven
um
and so in that imagery you see there are
plenty of stories that have that type of
imagery this whole Promethean notion of
stealing fire from the gods and bringing
it down to earth this is what Jack is
doing he's stealing fire from above he's
stealing gold Fire Light all these are
the same types of imagery meaning all of
this he's bringing down from above in
order for it to be able to to to uh
in order for it to to be able to be
beneficial to the Earth
um and that is also the reason why you
have you know and I've talked about this
before you have this notion of uh at
every level of transition you can have
monsters you can have monsters below you
but you can also have monsters above you
because the world is made of these of a
ladder of of of transcendence and so at
every step of the ladder you can
encounter some obstacle you can
encounter something which is going to
prevent you from going up further and
that can appear as some kind of a
monster you know like we've talked about
the the leprechaun that saves the goal
that's at the end of the rainbow there
are many images of uh we've talked about
the Sphinx or the Griffin which guards
holy places or even the Cherub which
guards the holy place you know on the
veil and so this idea that as you're
coming there's an obstacle or even the
Cherub at the Gate of the Garden of Eden
as you're moving in towards light
towards meaning towards identity there's
all there are also these obstacles which
can manifest themselves to you okay and
so the natural function of a hierarchy
is to distribute let's say the light
down to you so the idea you can imagine
a hierarchy of angels that distribute
the glory of God down to to the Earth or
you can imagine a hierarchy in terms of
a social hierarchy the purpose of the
hierarchy let's say to have a president
or a king or whatever it is that's above
you in terms of uh of uh of hierarchy is
that they are supposed to distribute
what they get from above them down to
the lower levels they're supposed to be
a conduit by which Grace by which uh
value by which identity all of these
things are supposed to come down to you
but like I said because of the very
manner in which hierarchy works it is
possible for the the the levels above
you to act as an obstacle and to prevent
let's say what's above from coming down
and that's the image the whole image of
the tyrannical King if you think of King
John and the story of Robin Hood who
only takes from below and doesn't give
from above you know and that that can't
work there has to be an exchange between
Heaven and Earth and so of course in the
darker side of this
type of representation of uh of of a
hierarchy of course there is an extreme
version of this which is you know the
kind of uh
the Revolutionary idea which is that we
have to go up and get the Tower of Babel
is also part of of this imagery of the
idea that we have to go up the tower in
order to reach to reach the highest you
know we have to go up and get it
ourselves because you know there is this
idea that it's not coming down the way
that we think it should come down or
that it it's being prevented from coming
down by the different levels of of an
ontological hierarchy
um and usually you know that's quite
negative but it's not doesn't always
have to be negative it just really
depends on what is behind it and what
you know
there is also this idea that we do have
to struggle there is a struggle that is
necessary in order to be able to access
you know it's a race we have to climb
the ladder and uh the ultimate image of
that is of course in the image of Jacob
now Jack and Jacob same name same story
I'm sorry to tell you that that uh Jacob
in the Bible is very similar to Jack in
the story of Jack and the Beanstalk
because Jack and the Beanstalk of course
is the trickster he goes up he tricks
the the um
he tricks the uh the Giant in order to
get things from above and that is
exactly what Jacob does in the Bible
Jacob tricks his father to get the
blessing because he sees his brother
who's above him adds an obstacle for him
to receive the blessing he tricks uh he
tricks Laban in order to to get value to
get uh to get rich
um and then ultimately he struggles with
an angel he fights an angel in order to
get a blessing uh and that is this it's
the same concept the whole story of
Jacob is the same thing so he me he
encounters an Angel and the angel is an
obstacle for him to receive the blessing
and so he struggles with the angel he
fights with the angel and then he
finally receives the blessing and so in
the most positive aspect of this story
we can see it as the need to struggle
and the need to to be to to actively
climb the ladder to active really engage
in life and not let the not let things
become obstacles for us to receive what
is coming from above and on the opposite
side or on the negative side and also
the negative side of Jacob as well is
the danger of the Revolutionary mindset
which is that I will overthrow what is
above me in order to get to to ascend in
order to get what is above from me and
in the the extreme version of that of
course the extreme extreme extreme
extreme version of that is of course
is of course the the revolution in
heaven or the revolution in the garden
and it leads to death uh and so there
are ways to recover let's say the the
the positive aspect of the story of
Jacob and of the story of Jack and the
Beanstalk and be careful of the
dangerous and negative aspects of that
story
so I hope that this uh this version this
explanation of the story of Jack and the
Beanstalk was enlightening to you
[Music]
I'm Jonathan Pedro and I'm inviting you
to participate with us in our retelling
and our celebration of one of the most
iconic fairy tales of all Snow White
a beautifully Illustrated storybook Snow
White and the Widow Queen places our
iconic character at the beginning of
eight upcoming fairy tales which will
speak to each other and harmonize in
surprising ways Snow White and the Widow
Queen rekindles an adventure which will
make you remember ReDiscover but also
Marvel and wonder at our Rich Heritage
of stories a Heritage that still has
secrets to reveal even after centuries
of being passed down to us in the past
few decades we have watched many of our
stories our fairy tales our myths become
completely exhausted by efforts to
deconstruct them to reinvent them and
sometimes to even invert their original
meaning it has come to a point where
we've almost forgotten why we cared
about these stories in the first place I
firmly believe that for this reason it
is now time to retell and redisrupt our
original fairy tales in a spirit of
celebration of admiration and unashamed
joy
I've spent the past two decades
meditating on the strange narrative
elements of Snow White and other fairy
tales after much thinking I'm now
bringing this story to our common Hearth
we find in the fire of time ready to
present Hidden Treasures most of us have
never noticed to accomplish this I have
paired up with Heather paulinton a
world-class artist and designer who has
worked on some of the most beloved film
franchises of our time her work mirrors
my writing and a collaboration that has
produced a powerful synthesis of
medieval style with the best of 19th and
20th Century illustration I love the
kickstarter model because we can make
the book more and more beautiful with
every stretch book who can offer art
prints a limited edition drawing by
Heather and even a snow white
illustration of my own
planning a super exclusive leather-bound
Edition which pulls out all the stops a
storybook mantelpiece for sure
the prophets of this crowdfunder will be
used to start a new Publishing Company
symbolic World Press whose christening
publication will be this very fairy tale
series
each book illustrated by world-class
artist Jack and the Beanstalk Cinderella
the Valiant little Taylor and several
more are next in line for publication
all existing in the same world and all
fitting together like a puzzle moving
towards the final surprising resolution
after all that there's no limit to what
we can do
it's time to reset the clock to retell
our stories so please join us in this
celebration and create Adventure
[Music]